So, this is the Doge version that Sarah can't stop playing. It's polite to
>> I need points.
>> So, this is based on
>> Still scoring.
>> The internet mean the Doge dog um,and this is just one
of you know, a ton of different modifications of this game that
is out here and you will have one yourself. How long do
you think it took the guys who made this to do this?
>> Honestly, for experienced programmers, probably like ten minutes. [LAUGH]
>> That's,
that's so cool. How long do you think it
will take our students to have their own version working?
>> Maybe a little more than ten minutes. Maybe like an hour. [LAUGH]
>> Okay,but to even just to make some little changes how long?
>> I could be doing that in minutes ,yeah.
>> Okay,so literally, this stuff isn't that hard. That
was, what was the most mind blowing to me when
I started going over how this all works and you'll
have your own version in ten minutes, so keep watching.